All right,
morning all.
Thank you all for coming again to day
two. We try to keep day two as the most
interesting day because I know as a
matter for a fact that people
[clears throat] tend to skip most or
half of the last day. So for me there
are only two parts of the conference
where I truly enjoy it. The evening
before where I can get to make friends
and have better time a better time and
an easier time socializing in the event
itself. And the last day where people
are now relaxed kind of and we can just
mingle have fun and truly learn and the
best presentations are here. Not that
I'm putting down all the people from
last from yesterday, right? Erin chose a
few really good ones because everybody
else sucked, right? I'm digging my own
hole. Are you noticing that? Like I'm
trying really hard and you guys are not
pointing at laughing. Anyway, let's get
started. [clears throat]
So statistics again, I have FOMO about
the online conference. What these people
have done is crazy. It's not just live
streaming. There are hosted sessions
with a lot of speakers just come in.
People just chat for a while without all
the noise in the background that it's
just insane what's going on over there.
850 people or so are active. Then there
is a drop off when Europe goes to bed,
but they already have videos because
aside to what we'll upload to YouTube,
Draos has been very good about saving
everything in the background, putting it
on Vimeo. It's just crazy what's going
on over there. So major FOMO. 700 people
in the venue. Not really not all the
time. I [clears throat] believe we're
averaging about 550 this today probably
around 450. And again I would just like
to stop. Thank the committee, thank the
staff, all the volunteers. Literally
some of the volunteers here are
professors, some are researchers, some
are CISOs, a couple of billionaires,
couple of students, somebody signific
somebody's significant other. Just
people are enjoying being a part of
this. I truly appreciate that. And
lastly toa again who can't be here today
and is pulling her hair would look like
mine after today is over because she's
pulling it not being here but managing
all of this naturally Andrea who stepped
in to help with all that but who to her
and two speakers who couldn't be here
because they're stuck in Israel with the
airspace closed. I want to extend some
thanks. So repeating yesterday's kind of
model
my thoughts in quick order. Number one
security. Yesterday I talked about the
nondeterministic deterministic
configuration becoming nondeterministic
and thinking what that means. I was
speaking for with my vendor hat on to a
customer a few weeks ago and he
suggested that the citizen coders
buzzword meaning not developers but
finance and HR and everybody else using
cloud code and cursor or moving to
lovable reple base 44. He's now is a
concern that's truly rising from him
right now. Now it's all the coding
agents but it's changing because
and this is big not because of incident
response not longer having auditability
or traceability not because of the
incident they already had which was
pretty interesting um where somebody
decided to bypass SSO and just put in
their authentication who hasn't s seen
developers do that before um wanting to
get to production but from finance and
not even the dependencies and
vulnerabilities where who knows these
applications exist not to mention
updating
But because literally he looks at this
and says in a world where everybody is
running their own infrastructure, it is
broken, is fragmented. How do we deal
with that? So that's my thought of the
day in security. The rest will be
quicker on startups in this under
startup era. I truly believe this is
going to be the reddest blue ocean I've
seen in my life. And think twice before
you enter this space and then enter it
anyway because it's so exciting. So
[\h__\h] exciting. Then on the team's
side,
[sighs]
it's been a day since yesterday and when
I shared I think we should all be on
cloud code and cursor and all these
tools right this second or we will all
be irrelevant. CEO, finance, devs,
doesn't really matter. So it's been a
day. Are all these people now the CEO,
the CISO, your people on cloud code
already? If not, you're already behind.
You had a day to change your lives and
you didn't do it. What's what's wrong
with you people? You work for the an
enterprise. Really? There's DPRM
processes? I don't know. I'm funny.
Laugh. Thank you. Thank you. And then
the power of the power user.
Um,
once you have your infrastructure, your
scaffolding in place, did you throw it
away yet? Are you looking at the cloud
code change log every week? Because if
you didn't, you're already behind once
again. And it's really not that hard.
It's exciting. Embrace it.
I will do this again today because I
feel really feel it matters. This is a
major fail partners of pattern of every
conference I've ever been to.
Questions are not comments. While I
appreciate contributions to everybody's
talks, that's not what it's about. So,
I'm going to read this out loud as
people say not to do in a presentation.
This is from Galani.
A question is an interrogative sentence
generally denoted by an inflection at
the end like this. A question differs
from a statement in that a question
requests information and a statement
provides it. We prefer questions to
statements and if you frame your
question as succinctly as possible
within 30 seconds we can get to as many
people as possible and we have the Slack
so please get on the Slack and workshop
your question so it's actually good with
everybody else get the engagement from
your friends and then the speakers will
get on and answer it anyway even if we
didn't get to it.